I like you know right in on the
motorcycle with my boyfriend I mean my
feelings your fiancee Perrie has that
newly engaged glow I have been spoken
for Matt and I speak for myself and I'm
very happy you're spoken for right now
yeah girl birthday Oh
the singer stopped by Jimmy Kimmel Live
to promote the upcoming season of
American Idol but the conversation
quickly turned to her recent engagement
to Orlando Bloom did you pick out your
reader did he pick out the ring I voiced
my opinion that's the way to go ya know
it was very sweet
we went to dinner and I thought we were
gonna go and see some art after dinner
but we pulled up to a helicopter he
asked me to marry him in a helicopter he
did land and it was like James Bond like
everybody had like an earpiece and then
we'd go downstairs we landed on a
rooftop and my whole family was oh
that's great
he did so well Orlando popped the
question three years after they first
hit it off Katie recalled the playful
moment that broke the ice we bonded over
an in-and-out burger about three years
at the Golden Globes he stole one off of
my table I was sitting with Denzel
Washington and he took it and I was like
wait oh you're so hot fine take it and
then I saw I'm at a party and I was like
how are those onions resting on your
molars it's like I like you and then you
know cut to it I think when you know you
when you're attracted to someone it's
kind of opposites attract and so I'm
looking for that balance and maybe he's
looking for that you know multitask on
such a multitasker the singer confirmed
the pair is living together and they're
enjoying all that comes with engaged
life including a tiff over Orlando's old
toiletry bags they went straight in the
trash and he didn't believe me he got
home he was very upset I had like a full
timeout
[Laughter]
[Music]